les shadoks que se sont réfugiés sur la
lune mais l'atmosphère de la lune et à
l'intérieur de la lune comme moi dont
les shadoks pouvait-il vivre et respirer
il n'avait pas de petits tuyaux
il ne permet pas d'être ou comme les
forts qu il ne vivait pas l'intérieur de
la lune non des shadoks sur la lune eh
bien il respirait avec leurs pattes une
pâte pour inspirer une pâte pour expirer
c'était même assez pratique étant donné
qu'ils pouvaient faire les deux en même
dans le sens pratique on dormira sur et
non il y avait un petit problème mais il
fut très vite résolu grâce à l'invention
géniale du professeur jadot co qui a
connu maintenant sous le nom de machine
à dormir debout
mais vous vous rendez bien compte qu'il
n'aurait pas été sain de respirer même
avec les pieds une atmosphère toujours
enfermés alors on était obligé tous les
dix jours ou trois semaines à un mois de
mettre l'atmosphère dehors pour me faire
prendre l'air c'était quand même assez
dangereux parce que lorsque l'atmosphère
était partie se promener la lune
naturellement se dégonflait mais
revenons à notre histoire